FILIP KNAPIK: Hello,
my name is Filip.
And I'm very happy
to be able to talk
to you about best
practices for development
and operations of Cloud Composer
environments and this way,
hopefully maximize the
benefits of using the product.
My name is Filip Knapik,
and I'm a product manager
for Cloud Composer, part
of the Google Cloud Team.
For those of you who are
familiar with Apache Airflow
but not that familiar
with Cloud Composer, what
you may need to
understand is that this
is a fully managed
Apache Airflow
product with full compatibility
to its open source counterpart.
Therefore, any DAGs
or workflows you
may want to run
with Apache Airflow,
you can also run it
in Cloud Composer.
And this way, it benefit from
a fully managed environment.
Now, it seems this is a
fully managed environment.
There are some features
that distinguish it
from a self-managed
Apache Airflow.
And I would like to
spend just a minute
to call these features
out so that we
understand how they differ.
And then we're going
to dive directly
into the best practices
for development
and operations of environments.
When it comes to benefits of
a Cloud Composer environment,
first of all, I would
cloud the deployment speed.
You can get started
with the product very,
very quickly and
practically in 20 minutes,
get an environment
up and running
without having any prior
experience with Apache Airflow.
And since this is a managed
environment, what you're also
gaining is the
fact that you don't
need to manage your own patches
or underlying components
and upgrade them as needed.
And you also don't need to
look into reliability metrics
and essentially worry about
having your product affected
by outages of
underlying component.
This is all taken care
of as a managed product.
The cost of using Cloud
Composer is predictable.
And I would even argue it
is well-optimized for use.
What I mean by this
is that it optimizes
for a total cost of ownership.
And, therefore,
the fact that you
don't need to manage individual
components of the platform
of the architecture
of the infrastructure,
you're saving time
that obviously
can be accounted for also
from a cost perspective.
Since this is a product
fully compatible
with open-source Apache
Airflow, the code
that you run in
Cloud Composer is
fully portable to its
open source counterparts.
And, therefore, you can
freely move your DAGs
into Cloud Composer
from Apache Airflow
and out obviously assuming we're
talking about the same versions
without a fear of being locked
into a specific platform
or specific product.
Enterprise customers
will specifically
appreciate the fact that
Cloud Composer comes
with multiple
security features that
are available out of the box.
And we're going to
cover some of them
later on in today's
presentation.
But elements, like private IP
or shared VPC or even network
perimeter are separated out
of the box by the environment.
And you don't need to spend
time on configuring those.
Last but not least, Cloud
Composer as a managed product
also comes with
technical support.
So in case there was
any outage or issue
that you may need to
have some help with,
you can always refer to
Google Cloud Support asking
for additional assistance.
Obviously that follows
your agreements
with the technical
support from Google Cloud
that you have in
your organization.
So without further ado, let me
dive into development practices
that hopefully will maximize
the benefit and experience
from using Cloud Composer.
Let me start with a somewhat
pessimistic but actually
optimistic message, which
is that every task can fail.
And while it may sound like
not that encouraging, what
I mean by this is
that, in fact, you can
and you should account
for potential failures
and build some
measures into your DAGs
that's recover
from those issues.
And a great example is using
a built-in retry policies
that can recover from issues,
for instance, network outages
and, therefore, get your DAG
properly executed, successfully
completed, even if a particular
task goes down because of,
for instance, a network issue.
So always remember about
building a proper retry
policies directly from
the very beginning.
And it shouldn't really
be an afterthought.
It should be a part of our
regular development practices.
However, for retrace
to work properly,
it is very important to
have your tasks important.
What I mean by this is
ability to run a specific task
multiple times and expecting the
exact same result every time.
Now, imagine that you
are creating some kind
of an entry in the database.
And you insert into
table using a command.
And then you have to
rerun the same task.
By doing so, you may end
up having multiple entries
simply duplicated in
the same database table.
That's probably not
the best approach.
And this task may not
be idempotent as such.
And, therefore, a better way to
handle the exact same request
is to, for instance,
insert or replace
with a specific key
that is assigned
to the specific transaction
and, therefore, if repeated,
will land in exactly the same
place in the database and worst
case, will simply
overwrite the same entry.
And this way, a
particular entry that
inserts the data
into the database
becomes idempotent
and works very well
with a potential
retry mechanism.
So always remember to
use retry and think
about idempotency of
the tasks that you're
orchestrating with it.
While developing Airflow
docks, it is very important
to leave the work that needs
to be implemented and executed
as part of your workflow
for operators and tasks.
There is a temptation
to put some logic,
some transformations
outside of the tasks
and outside of operators.
But the challenge
with doing that
is that Airflow doesn't really
then have a great visibility
into those activities
and also [INAUDIBLE]
delegate this work to
individual workers, which
is not ideal from end-to-end
management of your workflow
logic.
So the rule of thumb
should be to have your DAG
as a very simple and streamlined
piece of code that delegates
all of the work to individual
tasks that are implemented
using proper operators.
Speaking of operators,
you will also likely
need, obviously, as
part of the Airflow DAGs
to interact with
many other products.
And you may end
up in a case where
you realize that you have never
used a particular integration
before.
And you want to start creating
your own operator or a sensor
or a hook to essentially connect
to those external systems.
My hint on this
specific scenario
would be to always look into
whether there is already
an existing operator
or integration
created for that specific
interface and try to use that.
The community has put tremendous
amount of work and effort
into building operators that
are available for the most
common interfaces, the most
common products, and also
protocols and this way enable
a broad usage of Airflow
with orchestration of
those different products
and services.
So, again, instead of trying
to write their own operators,
always try to see if you can use
one of those that are already
there and benefit from what
the community has done.
And if you need to
create another one,
and you realize that somebody
else may benefit from it,
you may also consider
contributing it back
to the community.
While creating your
DAGs, you will often
get into cases where to properly
implement your business logic,
you need to be supported by
some modules that are delivered
outside of your specific DAG.
And typically you would
rely on PyPi modules--
basically PyPi
modules that extended
the capability of your DAG.
And the best way to manage
installation of the PyPi
modules is through a
built-in feature that
is available in Cloud Composer.
So this feature
allows you to define
which packages are necessary
for your individual DAGs.
And they are being installed in
the environment as a dependency
for your DAGs and
obviously makes
them available right away for
your DAGs in their execution.
One more hint I would
like to pass in here
is to avoid using a specific
version if you don't have to.
And leaving it blank means
your more future-proof.
And you're not specifically
limiting yourself to a version
that you have created and
used at this particular point
in time.
So, again, use the specific
version on if you really
have to for particular reasons.
There could be
cases where you may
want to create a
DAG that consists,
in fact, of a hierarchy
of different DAGs
or is somewhat modular.
And this could be to
abstract a piece of work
and keep it as a contained
piece of logic that's basically
a bigger DAG can interact with.
And there is
frequently a question
on how to best deal
with this scenario
should I use SubDAGs
or some other way.
And I will personally not
recommend using SubDAGs.
And the primary
reason is that there
could be some operational
issues with doing that--
[INAUDIBLE] locks and
many other scenarios.
And as such, probably
one of the best ways
to handle that specific case
is to use DAG Run Operator
instead.
And this way from a
particular task of a DAG,
make a request to other
DAGs and make them
executed as part
of your core DAG,
as we are sitting here
in this specific diagram.
So, again, use DAG Run
Operator instead of trying
to use SubDAGs if necessary.
So these were the high-level
development practices
when it comes to coding of your
DAGs that I wanted to pass.
But there is also a lot of
hints and recommendations
I would like to
share when it comes
to architecting your
Composer environments
or managing them moving forward.
So let me start with probably
one of the most important items
that I would like to
call out in this space.
And that is to upgrade your
environments frequently.
The Airflow coming into is
putting tremendous amount
of work and effort in improving
the quality of the product
and shipping features that the
community will benefit from.
Staying up to date with
the Airflow release
gives you access to all
of those new features
and bug fixes that the
community has created.
And the rule of
thumb is to not fall
behind more than
six months from what
has been announced or
shared by the community,
and this way not falling
behind basically the benefits
to those new releases bring.
Now, since the
upgrade process itself
can be somehow heavy
when it comes to effort,
there is a feature in Cloud
Composer that addresses
this challenge a little bit.
And that is the
upgrade feature that
allows you to upgrade
in environment in place
and prevents you
or avoids the need
for creating a new environment
moving all of your DAGs
over or, for
instance, even worse,
losing the history
of your DAG runs.
So, again, use the
upgrade feature
to keep your
environment up to date
and stay with the recent
version of Airflow
to benefit from all
the features it brings.
I also want to spend
a moment talking
about security
features, because this
is important for
multiple customers.
And obviously there is a
lot of security features
you can choose from.
And I highly encourage
you to look into those
and pick the ones
that are best suited
for your organization and
your individual needs.
The first one I would like
to call out is private IP.
With private IP called
Composer environments,
the nodes that are being used
for compute of Cloud Composer
are not assigned
public IP addresses.
So with that, they can't
really be addressed or accessed
from outside of the VPC network.
And as such are protected
from a networking perspective
from such access.
They still have access
to the outside world.
They can still reach
out to the internet.
But they simply cannot be
accessed from the outside.
Now, when it comes to the
web server of Cloud Composer
and user interface for
Airflow, the primary protection
mechanism and security mechanism
when accessing this component
is authentication.
So only authenticated
customers and users
have access to a specific
Airflow user interface.
However, some customers want to
have one more layer of security
for the web server as well.
And that is a network layer.
So if you want to have
network-level protection
for your Airflow
user interface, you
may want to use web server
access controls that's together
with private IP make
your environment not
accessible from the outside
world, unless the color belongs
to a predefined and whitelisted
set of IP addresses.
So this is like a firewall
setting that secures access
to your web server from
the outside world, which
you can use to configure
and further tighten access
to your Airflow web server.
Another feature that may
be used in conjunction
with other components
is VPC Native mode,
which puts your
Composer environment
and specifically
the GK classword
that it uses into
a VPC that allows
for access to other
components in the same VPC.
Customers that want
to have ultimate level
of network-level
protection may also
want to use a feature
called VPC Service Controls.
What this feature
gives is ability
to configure a network
service parameter which
becomes a standalone isolated
network that prevents access
from the outside world
but also prevents access
from within the parameter
to the outside world
creating a totally separate
and isolated network.
And services deployed into
such network perimeter
are ultimately secured from
network access perspective.
This setting, this
architecture also
comes with its own challenges,
because, for instance, you
can't easily use
externally hosted PyPi
packages because this network
connection is not available
anymore.
So while it comes with
additional complexities
to manage, it also comes
with increased security.
So some organizations may
choose to use this feature
to further secure their
Composer environments.
Two more features I would
like to call out for Composer
are shared VPC and
domain-restricted sharing.
With shared VPC,
you can create a VPC
that becomes a central hub
that multiple products connect
to and exchange information
with one another through that
hub only.
So this gives customers
a central place
of management for network
traffic and control.
And as such, if you create and
deploy Composer environment
to one of those projects,
participating in the shared VPC
setup, you gain a lot of
control over the network traffic
originated from this Composer
environment or coming into it.
So this is something
that some customers
may want to consider as well.
And the last security feature
I would like to call out
is the domain-restricted
sharing.
And this feature
allows customers
to restrict specific
domain names that
need to be there
in the addresses
of individual
accounts for access
to the Composer environment.
And as such, even if somebody
has been granted access
to your environment but does not
belong to a whitelisted domain,
which could be your
corporate domain name,
basically won't be able
to access your environment
without proper domain
name or email address.
So this is something
that customers can also
choose to further secure
their access to Composer
environments.
Another feature that
might be worth considering
is integration with Google's
Secret Manager as a way
to manage secrets for your DAGs.
It is very frequently the case
that when managing integrations
from Airflow DAGs
to other systems,
you need to use some
keys or some passwords
to connect to those
external systems.
And the question is, how do
you best manage those secrets
and keys while doing so?
The recommended
approach from my side
would be to use Google's
Secret Manager as a back end
for managing such secrets.
This integration has been
introduced in Airflow 1.10.10.
So we need to use that
version on [? newer ?]
and has also been recently
added to a Cloud Composer
environment.
And this is something
I would highly
recommend for all
the customers that
need to use secret keys,
passwords when integrating
with external systems.
This recommendation or hint is
almost too obvious to mention,
which is to separate production
from nonproduction environment.
And while it sounds
obvious, it is
important to call out that
as you create your production
pipelines that run your business
process and business logic,
you need to have a
separate environment
to test the newly created
DAGs or changes to those DAGs
separately from it.
And that's
particularly important
because, not only you need to
have management separation,
but you also need to have, well,
full domain separation, as well
as management separation
and performance and capacity
separation.
So for all those
reasons, you should
have at least two environments--
one for production-- one
for other use cases.
Obviously, you can end up
with multiple environments
for different stages
of your lifecycle
depending on how your
organization's implemented.
One more item I would
like to call out in here
is to also use CI/CD.
So as the deployment
process of DAGs
requires you to place
DAGs into the environment,
you want to make sure that you
control how this flow works.
And there is a lot
of different ways
you can establish CI/CD pipeline
that leads to a proper DAG
deployment.
We don't have a single solution
as part of our product.
But we have recommendations
in our website
that you may want to look
into on how to do it.
Again, there is not
a single solution
because there is not
a single architecture
that customers follow.
But, again I highly
encourage you
to look into the
documentation that we
have that may help you
establish those CIC pipelines
for your specific use cases.
And one more thing to add
in this specific scenario
is while you are having
your separate environments
for different
stages, please ensure
you're using the same
versions of Airflow
and also have the same versions
of dependent PyPi modules,
as, otherwise, the testing
may not be reliable enough.
Once you develop
all of your DAGs,
you need to ensure that they
run successfully in production
and deliver the right results.
And to help in
this specific need,
we have created a
monitoring dashboard
that is a landing page for
Cloud Composer environments.
And it consists of
different charts and metrics
that you can think of as
three different layers
of an abstraction in a way.
So the upper part, which I'm
going to show in the second,
covers statistics and
data around the DAG runs.
The middle part covers
Airflow processes
and the health of individual
Airflow components.
And the bottom part
covers the infrastructure
and, for instance, metrics
like CPU or memory consumption.
I'm not going to go
through every single chart
that we're seeing here.
What's really
important is to learn
how to read those
diagrams and see
the correlation between
different components
that may occur at the
same point in time.
So, for instance,
imagine that we're
seeing that specific
task started
failing at a point in time.
Then we can look into whether
a DAG bug size have changed.
And, for instance, this failure
that we have just witnessed
may be coming from newly
created and newly deployed DAGs
into our environment,
which actually, if we then
look into Airflow monitoring
or even more so, infrastructure
monitoring, we can realize that
while these new DAGs have cost
the CPU of the infrastructure
to be maxed out.
And, therefore,
lack of resources
is probably the reason for
the failure of the tasks.
So correlating those different
charts and metrics together
may help you understand the
story behind particular issues
or outages that you
might look into.
Obviously I'm not saying
that the monitoring dashboard
is the only way of
troubleshooting.
But it can be a
helpful tool in trying
to understand what
might have gone wrong
in some of the DAG executions.
One more recommendation I would
like to pass at this point
is to also establish your
own monitoring alerts
so that whenever something
goes wrong-- for instance,
you have an unprecedented
error ratio for your DAG runs
that you're notified
about those cases,
because nobody actually wants
to be looking into those DAG
reports all the time.
We're not currently shipping
any standard set of alerts
because there is not a single
solution on how to do it
and how to get notified.
But since all of the
metrics that you're
seeing in this dashboard are
available in the DAG driver,
you can create alerts
to get notified
about particular challenges.
And I highly encourage you
to look into that feature
and use it as well.
Obviously, what's
also very important
when it comes to troubleshooting
your environments
is looking into the logs.
Monitoring is obviously
not everything.
What's important and
where Composer also helps
is by showing you
all of the logs
from different components
of the infrastructure
in a single place.
So, for instance, as
you can see right now,
I'm currently highlighting
Airflow scheduler logs.
And, therefore, if I want
to look into specific issues
that scheduler may have faced
or may have thrown as errors,
I can easily see it
in a single place
coming from different components
of the infrastructure.
So that's a handy
tool when it comes
to troubleshooting
different issues
in different places of
the Composer and Airflow
environment.
What is also very
important when it
comes to ensuring that
your DAGs run successfully
is to scale your
environment accordingly.
And there are three components
in the infrastructure that you
can scale independently.
You can scale the Airflow
compute layer, which
is the educated cluster and
add more nodes as your needs
and, therefore,
gets more capacity
for processing your DAG
for running your workers,
for running your tasks
as part of your DAGs.
You can also increase the
size, basically, scale up
and, therefore, database.
If you have DAGs
that are particularly
effort-intensive at
a database layer,
you may choose a larger
database instance
and this way have
additional capacity
at that layer of
the infrastructure.
And the last component you may
want to consider scaling up
is the Airflow web server.
So specifically if you have
a lot of different DAGs
that the web server
has to process, orders
a lot of different users that
want to interact with it,
you may want to create a
slightly larger web server
to have the Airflow UI
with more capacity as part
of your workload.
However, what is very
important, as well,
when it comes to scaling
of the Airflow web server
is the next feature
I want to introduce.
And that is enable
DAG serialization.
So this is a feature
that is currently
not a default of the
Airflow environment
or if a Composer environment.
It may become one at some point.
But today in the
default approach
to implementation of
Airflow and Composer,
the web server is continuously
processing your DAGs,
trying to understand
what's inside
and how to visualize them,
and what these DAGs are.
If you enable DAG serialization,
however, the Airflow scheduler
is taking one more step,
one more responsibility.
And that is to
serialize the DAGs
and save the outcome
of that serialization
into the database.
From that point on,
the Airflow web server
is actually leading the
outcome of that serialization
instead of going through a
continuous endless loop trying
to run your code as
part of the web server.
And this is a significant
reduction of the work
that the web server
has to perform.
And also as such,
it is significantly
reducing the needs for
capacity of the web server
and the risk of a potential
instability of the web server,
because it no longer needs to
run any somewhat untrusted code
as part of the web server.
So this is a feature
I would highly
recommend to reduce the
load of the web server
and increase the stability
of the entire system.
So with that, let me very
quickly recap all the items
that we have gone
through very quickly
today as a way to
hopefully help you manage
and implement your DAGs in a
way that give you the biggest
benefit from using the product.
So, again, assume that
failures will happen
and are likely to happen even
for the best and the most
reliable end points and to
use built-in, retry, and error
handling mechanism in Airflow
and, therefore, make your DAG
runs not vulnerable to
those issues and successful
practically all of the time.
To support that also,
make your tasks idempotent
so that they can
be safely retried
without an unexpected
consequences as part
of your DAG executions.
Leave the work to the operators.
Don't try to put the
code in between the tasks
between the operators so
that Airflow can properly
manage the distribution
of the work and errors
that may arise from it.
Use existing Airflow
integrations,
all the operators,
hooks and sensors
that the community has created.
It's a very long and
comprehensive list
and very helpful in getting
you started with most
of the systems around.
Take time to manage
the Python modules.
Ideally without
specifying the versions,
use the ones that are
available already.
Upgrade your environment
as frequently as you can.
And ideally, don't exceed
the window of six months
without an upgrade because this
can render your environment
as outdated and lacking
the recent bug fixes
and improvements.
Use built-in enterprise
security features.
Since this is a long list
of potential features,
you may need to
choose the ones that
fit your organization and
your security policies
and regulations.
But look into those, please,
and choose ones accordingly.
For managing of your secrets
and keys with other systems,
highly recommend to use
Secret Manager as a way
to manage basically
all of those components
that you need to have
for your integrations.
Use separate for the known
for the environments,
use CI/CD, and
ensure you're running
the same versions in
all the environments
with the same packages.
Use Composers built in
monitoring dashboards and logs.
And if possible, also establish
and set up your own outlets
so that you get notified on any
potential outages and issues
that you may encounter.
Scale your environment
accordingly,
remembering that these are three
different elements that you
can scale independently-- the
compute layer, the database
layer, and the web server.
And then use the
DAG serialization
to reduce the load
of the web server
and increase the stability
as a component of
the overall platform.
With that, I wanted to thank
you very much for attention.
I hope some of those
hints where useful.
And I'm looking forward to
see you using Cloud Composer
and contributing also to
Apache Airflow community.
Thank you very much.